[Music]
are you willing to like full-on all sing
along with me sure yeah would anybody
like to sing a song like singing what
those are not of my choice
yeah like 20 seconds 20 seconds I'm down
so I just saw it gave you her head and
you tossed it in the trash you tossed it
in the trash you did to give me all your
love was all I ever asked cause what you
don't understand is I'd catch a grenade
for you throw my head on a blade for you
oh my god 50 seconds how do you feel I
like it was P my
I don't sing in front of people that was
so good in front of people you think so
I got my wiper here loving you is easy
cause you're beautiful
doo doo doo
[Laughter]
and that guy saw like I can be honest no
[Music]
you got you gotta overcome those moments
where you need to just you know I think
go off you know somehow I try to do that
because that's where you get growth I
like to say you know the more you
overcome those fears or all right no
it's true the more you overcome fear
there's like that it makes you grow no I
stretched yourself so I'm always about
that so yeah sure Noel is man one the
world in my hands hate the beach but I
stand in California with my toes in the
sand house that was good this
neighborhood it's one of my favorite
bands Old MacDonald had a farm eieio and
on his farm he had a cow moo moo moo
what is it like an actual circuit yeah
come away with me tonight come away with
me and
I wanna write you a song and I wanna
wake up on a cloudy day in fields where
the yellow grass grows knee-high so
won't you come come away with me okay
okay so I used to do some opera actually
so yeah it's not gonna sound great but
I'll try it
[Music]
you believe then it's that donut donut
that you're insecure don't know what for
you're turning heads and you like the UH
don't need make-up to cover up being
okay that you are is enough everyone
else in the room can see it everyone
else but you and if I ever fall in love
again
[Music]
I will be sure that the lady is a friend
and if I am ever fall in love so true I
will be sure that the ladies just like
you
I don't saying I was just some light you
know so I'm not doing this shower
[Music]
so don't me far so lucky though mine I'm
the first in line honey I'm still free
take a chance on me if you need me let
me know gonna be around if you got no
place to go and you're feeling down yeah
check two one two I mean like a wrap we
could do the rap I don't know the right
but I'll wrap it was all a dream
I used to read Word Up Magazine some
pepper than Heavy D up in the limousine
hanging pictures on the wall every
Saturday rep attack mr. magic
mother-in-law I let my tape brought to
my tape pop hidden bamboo pit sippin on
private stock way back when I had the
ready black lumberjack with the hat to
match
remember rapping Duke the heart AHA you
never thought that hip hop could take
this far now I'm in the limelight
because I'm running tight time to get
paid blow up like the world chain once
in the opposite of a winner I remember
one night you see sardines food in the
PISA root I forgot I forgot I'm done I
don't get though you know song that is
yeah I am I good
a tornado flew around my room before you
came excuse the mess you made
okay I have like a shower song but it's
it's from this really old movie called
Seven Brides for Seven Brothers have you
heard of it really it's a non bad guy
okay a lonesome polecat lonesome Dan boo
thank God no feminine' PO can howl at
the moon
[Music]
a man can't sleep when he sleeps with
sheep yesterday all my troubles seemed
so far away now it looks as though
they're here to stay oh I believe in
yesterday suddenly I'm not half the man
I used to be there's a shadow hanging
over me Oh yesterday came suddenly why
she had to go I don't know she wouldn't
say
I said something wrong now I long for
yesterday yesterday love was such an
easy game to play now I need a place to
hide away oh I believe in yesterday it's
seven o'clock on the dot
I'm in my trap top cruising the streets
I got a real pretty thing that's waiting
at home for me I pulled up anticipate it
full of oh I've been waiting I've been
waiting from my head I said it's very
fun somebody I just want to get nice and
slow tell me what you want to do
[Music]
hey everyone you may have noticed that I
reloaded this episode I do want to like
first of all apologize to all of you
guys and everyone in the episode for the
approach I took originally it's hard to
explain
this cuz I don't want it to sound like
I'm making excuses for like for a
mistake I made but I really hope you
guys know that like my intentions were
never and are never to hurt anyone's
feelings I think I got caught up and
like the fun of making that pisode even
with the people who were in it like
everyone knew what the episode was gonna
be like that it was like a competition
and you either got your Instagram
plugged or you got a no and we thought
like me and the people participating we
thought that it was funny and fun but I
think as a editor and as a creator
sometimes we have to take a step back
and realize that people who are viewing
it don't get to see the behind the
scenes and it could come off the wrong
way which is exactly what happened with
the first version that I uploaded and
that's my fault I should have seen that
and I should have known before I
uploaded like I don't know what I was
thinking I'm thankful that you guys were
able to help me figure it out and redo
the episode in a way that I think is ten
times better
as long as I'm making videos if you ever
think that I'm doing anything that isn't
kind just let me know and I'll make the
change
[Music]